Speaker 1: All right, I don't know if we call
this an exercise in irony or an exercise in,
I mean, listen, I don't know, maybe if you
believe in karma and these types of things,
maybe that's the way you interpret this. But a
Republican is going to be unable to attend an
anti-vaccine rally because he now has COVID and
is treating COVID with all sorts of unproven
treatments. It's another one of these stories.
This is being reported in the New York Daily News.
A Republican lawmaker in North Dakota will
miss his Monday rally opposing vaccine mandates
because he has COVID instead. Representative
Jeff Hobson says he will stay home and take a
cocktail of medications, including the
unproven anti parasite drug ivermectin
and the malaria remedy hydroxychloroquine. That's
Jeff Halverson showing a picture of him now.
COVID is real and like a really bad flu, he
wrote on Facebook. I am currently quarantining
and each day is getting better.
Halvorson claims that his home remedy,
which is popular with right wing pundits, a lot
of right wing pundits now give medical advice.
It's interesting. Should be more widely used by
the public, he noted. Noted he's not hospitalized
and he's on the mend. He posted to Facebook,
Thank you brave soul for getting me ivermectin,
which now with COVID, I am able to stay out of the
hospital. COVID is real and like a really bad flu.
Quarantining and each day is getting better.
Ivermectin. Hydroxychloroquine, vitamins,
etc. According to hundreds upon hundreds of
medical experts, including in North Dakota, should
be our early ambulatory care. Upon diagnosis,
give the kits, call and tell the state health
department to stop misleading the public about
these available treatments. Look for yourselves.
Take your pick of experts. Lists a number of
people. Why is North Dakota providing cover
for pharmaceuticals? We should be keeping people
out of the hospital. It may not surprise you
that this lawmaker is also a pastor. He told The
Associated Press he tested positive last week for
coronavirus. He said three of his teenage children
will go to the anti-vaccine rally. He is a father
of six. Halvorson has battled mask mandates, was
barred from boarding a flight with his wife late
last month because of an issue with a pat down and
said his wife, he and his wife were traveling for
their anniversary. Imagine, imagine for a moment.
In the future, explaining to people, you know,
we had this pandemic and millions died, millions
globally died, but then we got a vaccine and then
there was a rally. There was a rally about the
vaccine. Oh, and the rally was for people to get
vaccinated, right? No, no. The rally was against
vaccination. What? Imagine explaining it to a kid
today. Imagine saying to, you know, little Sophie
or little Mordechai. That they're protesting for
vaccines, right? No, they're not. But dad, don't
they want everybody to get vaccinated so that we
end the pandemic? No, no, no, no. Little, Sophie.
They want people not to get the vaccine. What?
What? It's a very, very ugly episode in American
history, and this here's one guy who would have
been at the protest at the rally, but he's home
with COVID, so he's not going to be able to do it.